welcome to our mega makeover hour
i'm walking living proof
i mean look at me i keep walking past a
mirror and being like who is that
the power of hair and makeup and clothes
it should be about confidence and
empowerment and a feeling but it is
pretty remarkable what those things can
do to someone
and we have just sent 25 deserving
teachers backstage for brand new looks
and if that isn't the most important i
don't know what is
but let's answer your biggest questions
and solve all of your beauty and fashion
dilemmas because our makeover mega dream
team is here it's chris appleton brandes
danielle and charlotte tilbury
time for a mega makeover live check in
with the amazing chris hasselton
who is backstage
i wanted to talk to you about a couple
of things drew first of all humidity um
a lot of people keep
humidity and the problems that she has
with it um my go-to is this game changer
this is the color whale dreamcoat this
magically transforms the texture of hair
and it actually locks out humidity so if
the hair you know goes into a damp
atmosphere or if you go into a humid
atmosphere it actually has waterproof
technology so it can't get in so we've
got your back covered and then we also
prepped her hair with the um colorwell
raise the roof for some extra volume to
really pump up the volume because she
wanted like a glossy smoother finish but
she didn't want it flat to her head we
wanted a little bit of vavavoom and a
bit of sexiness that never goes out of
fashion oh kim you are looking so
beautiful you really are
well chris i'm happy to share with
everybody that thanks to you everyone in
the audience is gonna go home with
colorwell's dream coach yes
you too
can get this look it's our mega makeover
all show long we've been transforming 25
amazing teachers backstage with the help
of our mega makeover dream team and it's
time for the big reveals i mean dream
teams i i i can't even believe i'm
standing next to charlotte tilbury
brandes daniel and chris appleton
[Applause]
are you ready to show off your work
absolutely let's do it all right we're
gonna do a rotation um first up is amy
melissa hannah and stacy come on out
[Applause]
oh you guys are so beautiful
all right for this one brandeis tell us
what you did yeah you know it's all
about a pop of color we're getting ready
to go into the spring season and there
is nothing that makes you feel better
than just really bright
colors also if you take a look all of
them have been accessorized really well
with really great jewelry really great
earrings as well and so they just all
look absolutely beautiful how do you
feel
amazing
that's what we always say right if you
look amazing you feel amazing and it's
just you're beaming like the rays are
just coming out of you about how
gorgeous you look and i always say to my
daughters where is it the most important
to be beautiful and they go on the
inside
i'm like yes exactly
thank you ladies so much thank you thank
you thank you
so stunning okay next up four besties
from the southeast elementary school in
mansfield connecticut their friends and
family are in the audience come on out
liliana susan kate and
[Applause]
again emily guys all are beaming with
bright smiles kate's husband jim is in
the audience jim what do you think
she looks so different uh i wanted to
say though that katie and all of
teachers are beautiful before makeovers
yeah but um absolutely
she's amazing now it's such a
transformation looks great i couldn't
agree more thank you ladies
and next up we have
jackie violetta and mia
oh my gosh
you guys look so beautiful i'm so
honored that you guys would give time to
spend with us here today so that we can
honor you and charlotte may i ask what
did you do with these beautiful ladies
oh darling so we put on i don't know if
you've realized that there's one color
so i put this beautiful dreamy soft
rose pink on you on me and on all your
girls and it just is a very flattering
universally pretty shade and i just
wanted to prove that if you put that on
everyone it just makes everyone just
glow and look romantic and soft and
beautiful and it doesn't matter what
skin color you have what hair color you
have it looks beautiful on everyone it's
it's this
part of my range that just it just i see
it on you i see it on you and when you
looked in the mirror and you saw your
eyes and we did the kind of we kind of
enhanced your eyes everyone's got to
look gorgeous absolutely and so do you
thank you ladies
[Applause]
[Music]